okay we're somewhere in the Catskill
Mountains I don't know exactly where
where Hudson this is RAM tot we're going
out to film a Russian movie right now
I'm playing a Russian mob boss no that's
a joke look at that look at that look at
that look at that look at that strange
thing is not having internet not having
internet because it's it's extremely
isolating what are those walls their
original property markers that Dutch
settlers built in the 1600s they don't
they aren't used now like our property
lines are on paper the faithful crossing
our Qaida's been doing this for
thousands of years you can do this this
is all green underneath the moss is
there what it's just froze
that's the destination that we're going
to you going down there
oh my god man put it down there through
the jump in summertime if you went in
there you know fear for this
which is the inspiration to all of us I
gotta go back up it's
after being in the city for a long time
you get used to buildings and activity
and all that stuff here so it's sort of
shocking it's a stunning feeling to be
in silence I think we all need to change
environments every once in a while just
so that we can get out of our own heads
this is a wonderful place that's so nice
mild winter for when it's not too cold
you